the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what sob ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 Theory video what I want to talk about
today is actually my favorite theory of
mine ever since I created my channel I
have made over 350 different videos
about Game of Thrones
I have given my thoughts on pretty much
every character that is still active in
the show but out of all those videos
this is the one I like the most I was
already very confident about this theory
but I have some more evidence that I
think backs it up even more now I do
have to admit most of this evidence was
taken directly from the books but I
still think there is a very good chance
it can happen in the show too there is
some foreshadowing for this in the
television show as well not to mention
Dan and Dave did talk to george RR
martin about how his books will end i
know some of you have seen my other
video about this theory but even if you
have I still think you will like this
video because I'm including some extra
evidence my last video did not have
before we get started I do want to thank
the sponsor today's video this video is
sponsored by Squarespace and whether you
need a domain a website or even an
online store I would highly recommend
that you check out Squarespace now as
you can see by the title of this video I
want to talk about what I think it will
take to defeat the night king for good
this is something that I think almost
all of us have thought about I know I
have ever since the White Walkers were
first introduced in the opening episode
now obviously we did not see the night
King at that time but I always wondered
what it would take to stop the White
Walkers we know they can be killed by
dragonglass and Valyrian steel weapons
but we still don't know what it will
take to stop the night king some fans
assume you can kill the night king by
using those same weapons but I don't
think that's true since he is the leader
of the White Walkers I think it will
take a very special weapon to stop him
for good now some of you might think a
dragon can stop him but I don't think
that's the answer either not only did we
see the night King walk right through
the dragon fire but we also saw him kill
a dragon any
actually kind of made it look easy so I
highly doubt it would be a dragon that
kills him
I still think one of our beloved
characters will have to challenge him to
one versus one combat we know the knight
King has a magical ice sword that hangs
across his back the one and only time we
actually saw the knight Cain kill
someone was when he killed the
three-eyed Raven that was when we
finally saw the knight king use that
magical ice sword now since this is a
Song of Ice and Fire
we will need that balance on the
opposite side in order for someone to
defeat the knight King they will need a
magical sword made of fire this was
actually already foreshadowed in the
second season of the show during
Melisandre introduction we saw a burning
sword when she held the ceremony on the
beach at Dragonstone now how many of you
actually think it's a coincidence that
this is what we saw during Melisandre
introduction into the show I believe we
will see the same thing happen during
Melisandre as final scene in the show
when we first meet Melisandre on the
beach at Dragonstone we can hear her say
after the long summer darkness will fall
heavy over Westeros stars will bleed the
cold breath of winter will freeze the
Seas and the dead shall rise in the
North in the ancient books it's written
that a warrior shall draw a burning
sword from the fire and that sword shall
be Lightbringer in the ancient books
it's written that a warrior will draw a
burning sword from the fire
and that sword shall be Lightbringer
basically what that means is after the
long summer ends the long night will
fall over Westeros in order for someone
to defeat the dead and end the long
night they will need a burning sword
that can bring the light back into
Westeros that's why the sword is called
light bringer it brings the light to the
darkness the only problem is you have to
find the right characters to be able to
create that sword as you can see in that
scene
Melisandre had a burning sword sticking
into the chest of one of the statues on
the beach at Dragonstone at that time
Melisandre thought Stannis Baratheon
would become azor Ahai reborn
Melisandre thought Stannis was the one
that was meant to carry that sword into
the darkness they do need a burning
sword but Stannis is not the one that is
meant to carry it we begin to find out
who is meant to carry that sword in the
very last book that was released which
is a dance with dragons
I believe we get several big clues about
who will become azor Ahai reborn only
this character will have to stick the
sword into a living heart to create
light bringer Melisandre was using those
statues during the ceremony but when the
time comes for this sword to actually
get created someone will have to
sacrifice their self to get the sword to
catch on fire now I don't know how many
of you saw my original video but I
believe Melisandre will have to
sacrifice herself in order for the
prophecy to come true I think Melisandre
now realizes this will have to happen
which is why she told Varys she will
come back to Westeros one last time to
die it's already set in motion I will
return this fighter
one last time my lady I have to die in
this strange country I think we got one
of the clues during Melisandre and
John's last conversation together this
was when John exiled Melisandre from the
north for sacrificing Shireen Baratheon
John said that Melisandre would be
killed if she ever came back to the
north but it was what Melisandre said
that I want to show you this is where we
get some of our hints I've been ready to
die for many years if the Lord was done
with me so be it but he's not you've
seen the night King Jon Snow
you know the Great War still to come you
know the army of the Dead will be upon
us soon and you know I can help you win
that war one of the very last things
Melisandre says to John is I've been
ready to die for many years so we
already know that Melisandre is prepared
to die she even knows she will die
because that's what she told Varys the
last time we saw her but she also knows
that she has one last thing to do
Melisandre told John she can help him
defeat the night king but she never did
say how she can defeat the night king so
it's obvious Melisandre still knows
something that we don't she knows how to
beat him and she knows she will die I
think it will actually be Melisandre
sacrifice that enables them to stop the
night king this is why she is ready to
die this is why she knows she will die
and this is why she knows she can help
John defeat the night king after all the
sacrifices Melisandre has done it will
be her final sacrifice that has the
biggest impact this whole time all she
needed to do was sacrifice herself to
the right character for the prophecy to
come true Melisandre has even told us
death by fire is the purest death now
let's take a look at some of the text
let's see what the original is or 'hi
had to do to create Lightbringer make
sure you look very closely at the words
because we will see them again in some
of the other chapters about Melisandre I
just want to take a look at what it says
right at the moment the sword is stuck
into nice aneesa's chest
it says Nissa Nissa he said to her for
that was her name barrier breast she did
this thing why I cannot say in azor Ahai
thrust the smoking sword through
living heart it is said that her cry of
anguish in ecstasy left a crack across
the face of the moon try to remember
that text because how it was worded is
the key to Melisandre being nice Anissa
now let's break it down sentence by
sentence that way I can show you that
Melisandre is without a doubt nice
Anissa the first thing you need to
understand is how the sword can catch on
fire if it's stuck in a Melisandre heart
how would that actually make a catch on
fire well we have been told time and
time again that Melisandre has a fire
burning inside of her there are a number
of different quotes in the books that
indicates this not only do they mention
Melisandre has fire burning inside of
her but one of them just flat-out says
Melisandre is fire and her hair is even
blood in flame we get another clue when
Jon and Melisandre are riding in the
elevator together this is when Jon finds
out how Melisandre is able to be at the
wall without wearing heavy fur coats
like all the men of the Nights Watch Jon
says you are not cold my lady Melisandre
laughs at this she says never then the
Ruby at her throat starts to pulse in
time with the beating of her heart
Melisandre says the Lord's fire lives
within me Jon Snow this scene happens in
the show and in the books there is a
good reason why we are told this that's
because we need to know Melisandre has
fire burning inside of her that way when
the sword is stuck into her heart we
will know why it catches on fire this is
actually shown right on Melisandre is
very own banners we have seen this
symbol ever since Melisandre was
introduced Melisandre literally has a
burning heart rate on her flag now one
of the most fascinating clues in my
opinion is when Jon thinks about the way
Melisandre smells Jon notices this at
the same time Melisandre tells him she
has a fire burning inside of her again
this is when they are riding in the
elevator together it says in the close
confines of the iron cage he was acutely
aware of the red woman's presence she
even smells red the scent reminded him
of my concern smelled when Red Hots the
scent was smoking blood kissed by fire
this says Melisandre smells like a forge
which we all know that is where swords
are created thus
mell reminds John a mic ins Forge the
way iron smells when you melt it down
and it turns red hot the scent was
smoking blood
Melisandre smells like that because she
is meant to have a sword forged inside
of her she already smells like that now
let's take a look at another clue from
the show this is when Melisandre and
Johnson are at Castle black together
this happens during the scene when we
see Melisandre try to seduce Jon what I
find interesting about this scene is
Melisandre actually talks about her and
Jon creating something together and you
can guess what she references Melisandre
says they can create lights I believe
that is a reference to light bringer
Tiffany had pity
[Music]
this power in you
you resist it and that's your mistake
embraces you're not joining this power
power to make life power to make light
did you notice what Melisandre did right
before she said that to John she bared
her breasts which is what nice and Nisa
did right before Zora hi stuck his sword
into her chest
Melisandre bears her breasts then she
talked about creating lights okay so
let's go over what we know so far
Melisandre has told us she has a fire
burning inside of her Melisandre never
gets cold and John even notices she
smells like a burning sword then
Melisandre tells John they can create
light together
Melisandre also told John she can help
him defeat the night King and she told
Varys she will die next season are you
starting to notice the connections here
let's continue now let's go back to the
prophecy let's take another look at that
text it says azor Ahai thrust the
smoking sword through our living heart
notice how it says living heart it
doesn't just say heart now let's take a
look at what Davos says when he thinks
about killing Melisandre this is shortly
after the battle at Blackwater Bay
notice how he references a Melisandre's
heart it says I will cut the living
heart from her breast and see how it
burns not only does it reference a
living heart just like the prophecy does
but it also references a burning heart
and this is directly connected to
Melisandre now let's take a look at the
prophecy again this time I want to look
at the last sentence after the sword is
stuck into her heart it is said that her
cry of anguish and ecstasy left a crack
across the face of the moon I want to
focus on the word ecstasy if you go
through all five books that george RR
martin has released an A Song of Ice and
Fire you can only find the word ecstasy
five times in all of those books the
very first time we see the word ecstasy
in the books is during this prophecy but
the other times we see this word in the
books are all references to Melisandre
that is not a coincidence my friends
this is what it says in Melisandre is
very own chapter in fact it's her one
and only chapter so far
it says the red priestess shuddered
blood trickled down earth i blackened
smoking the fire was inside of her in
agony in ecstasy filling her
during her transforming her now let's
take a look at one of the other times we
can see the word ecstasy in the books
this time it's describing the way
Melisandre cries and it sounds exactly
like the way Nissa Nissa cried
this happens when Melisandre is giving
birth to the shadow baby this is what
Davos notices it says blood ran down her
thighs black is ink her cry might have
been agony or ecstasy or both
when Nissa Nissa cried it says her cry
was of anguish and ecstasy when
Melisandre cries it says her cry was of
agony or ecstasy like I said these are
the only times you can find that word
used in all five books so now that we
know who nice aneesa's let's take a look
at who is or 'hi is now if you remember
Melisandre originally thought Stannis
Baratheon was a Zora hi but in the very
last book that was released we get a
clue about who is really a Zora hi we
find this out in Melisandre's one and
only chapter thus far when Melisandre
looks into the fire she prays for a
glimpse of azor Ahai but the only thing
we're lower shows her is snow now look
at the way George R Martin wrote that
sentence the word snow is actually
capitalized that's because he is
referencing a character's name as in Jon
Snow he is not talking about the snow
that falls from the sky so whenever
Melisandre looks into the fire to see
who is or 'hi is the only thing she can
see is snow we get another very good
clue in the same book this time it
happens during one of Jon Snow's dreams
in this dream it says Jon Snow is
armored in black ice and he has the
burning red sword in his fist
this is why it's Jon Snow who notices
Melisandre never gets cold and he
notices Melisandre smells like a burning
red sword
George are Martin is leaving these
breadcrumbs all throughout Jon and
Melisandre chapters there is a reason
why it's Jon who notices these things
now let's take a look at something else
in the books maester aemon actually
leaves Castle black was a mole Tarly
they traveled all town together when Sam
goes to try to become a maester now
right before maester aemon leaves Castle
black
he gives Jon Snow a book there is one
section in the book that maester aemon
really wants Jon Snow to read
he makes sure to leave a bookmark in
that section he wants John to look at
when John opens the book to that section
it tells us a story about a Zora hi and
Nissa Nissa when John reads the chapter
about Ozora hi in Nissa Nissa we also
get another clue that connects
Melisandre and Nissa Nissa together
let's see what it says Lightbringer was
never cold to the touch but warm as
Nissa Nissa had been warm
this means Nissa Nissa was never cold
either as in she must have had a fire
burning inside of her too just like
Melisandre the evidence almost becomes
overwhelming once you actually step back
and take a look at it all
Melisandre welcome back to Westeros one
last time to give the ultimate sacrifice
not only did she say she is ready to die
but she also knows she will die
she told John she can help him defeat
the night king and I think this is how
she will accomplish that the fire that's
burning inside of Melisandre will
consume Jon Snow's sword once he shoves
it into her hearts death by fire is the
purest death let me know what you think
about this updated video let me know if
you think Melisandre is nice on ISA
leave your thoughts down below before I
go I do want to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring today's video for those of
you that don't know you can use
Squarespace to help build your own
website like I said before I used to
think it was very difficult to create
your own website but Squarespace makes
their service very easy to use and
understand they do have an all-in-one
platform that even provides 24/7
customer support if you are thinking
about creating your own website I would
highly recommend that you go to
squarespace.com for your first free
trial then once you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com slash talking
Thrones to save 10% off your first
purchase go to the description of this
video to find their link thank you all
very much I hope everyone has a great
day and I hope to see you all come back
when the final season begins in just a
few days thanks for watching I will see
you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you